so for this week's classic interview we
are dealing with an important issue but
it's also Thanksgiving and we've been
hearing from Pat about vegan
Thanksgiving and vegan shepherd's pie
with lentils and people are demanding
the recipe from him on our subreddit so
we're going to go back to when I
interviewed Brian man oh it's who is
known as the vegan black metal chef he's
both a extraordinarily heavy metal
musician whom former producer Louis was
a big big fan of and also a vegan chef
so this is a shout out to it's not
really a shout out to anybody actually
but it sort of relates to Thanksgiving
and we're having a good time and
Thanksgiving is tomorrow or yesterday or
the day before depending on when you're
watching this but let's get right to it
my interview from February of 2016 with
Brian man oh it's vegan black metal chef
I'm joined today by Brian man oh it's
known to those who know him as the vegan
black metal chef Brian let's start with
the sort of simplest question first how
long have you been vegan and why
greetings listeners of the David Pakman
show and Watchers I've been vegan for
about 15 or so years and the fast answer
I tell people is I don't believe in the
exploitation of animals and talk about
what that means to you in in terms of
veganism vegetarianism etc is there any
scenario in which animal products are
consumed that wouldn't be exploitation
to you or or is any consumption of
animal products whatsoever exploitative
in your mind well I believe is where we
were talking earlier quite some time ago
believe you had mentioned something like
if someone was if it was some native
tribe somewhere that was living just off
the land and and something like that
would that be considered exploitation of
animals and to that I say no if if it
was some any of the
the very few still existing native
tribes that just live off the land I'm
not talking to them quite honestly I'm
just talking to the city to world that
and especially sort of the the first
world which I'm not sure if the u.s. is
a part of anymore or not but but mostly
the the citied world and and and even
sort of world city world but yeah but
the the people in what we would consider
relatively normal circumstances so it
sounds like if I understand correctly
part of whether animal consumption
either either of animal meat or animal
products whether it's exploitative in
your mind depends on sort of the life
situation of those who might be
consuming the animals in terms of the
alternatives they have and my
understanding that yeah in one sense yes
I mean you can only take the ivory tower
so far in the sense that at some point
really the basics of veganism is these
animals that that we consume and that we
use are living their life in utter hell
basically for for our benefit which is
not needed and so that's really the
bottom line of everything is we want to
cut out that whole these animals living
in utter hell and the best part of their
life is their death so um there might be
some fringe circumstances about this or
that but it's really not important in
the big scheme of things I'm curious
though if you hold that or believe that
taking an animal that didn't necessarily
choose to be born it also certainly
didn't choose to be used for food or for
its products to be taken by humans for
consumption and you say well in the city
it's exploitative to do this to the
animal but in a rural place it isn't it
might be hard for some people to sort of
understand if you believe that morally
if the animal doesn't have a say in the
matter it's exploitation why is it not
exploitation merely because humans might
be living in an area
they have fewer alternatives I'm trying
to understand the sort of consistency of
that absolutely absolutely what I say
rural I don't honestly mean like rural
America now I get it I get yeah it's
still quite I'm talking about if you're
some kind of native tribe if you're an
Eskimo there's zero vegetation around
then and that's what you live off the
land then yeah if that's what you
absolutely have to do to survive then
yeah I I don't have a problem with it
because ultimately there's sort of two
sides of it there's sort of the moral
side which which is sort of what I'm
talking about here and then there's also
the ultimate the the relative sense in
that morals have moral actions have
consequences and the ultimate sense in
that they're they're essentially are no
morals so in the ultimate sense that's
what I'm talking about with these native
tribes is that there really is no moral
aspect here they're they they're doing
what they need to do to survive just
like the rest of nature they're living
in nature I'm furious though I'm curious
though because if you go back before the
Agricultural Revolution for example
where a human said hey you know what
instead of sort of being nomadic and
having a hunter-gatherer lifestyle we're
going to settle down here and do and
grow and depend on wheat or whatever it
is prior to that when humans were
nomadic and sort of hunter-gatherers
they would their meat consumption in
many cases was mostly the leftover
animals that some larger stronger
predator had killed and otherwise they
were mostly eating berries and what
could be found naturally right plants
vegetables etc so is it even a good
argument to say that you make exceptions
now for those who are in these native
areas when even when we go back pre
Agricultural Revolution
excuse me we still had a lot of humans
that were able to get by without
certainly killing meat if not eating it
at all that doesn't it sound a little
bit strange to make the argument out of
necessity now when we have examples of
non meat eaters from so long ago well
here's the thing it doesn't even cry
by mine because it doesn't matter like
we're talking about Sophie people and
such a nothing in the grand scheme of
things that it's totally off the point
it's the it's it's it it literally
doesn't matter
like if it like in terms of all the
other benefits of veganism to the planet
to society and everything else
those those fringe cases don't matter oh
my god they don't matter to you anyway
they don't matter to me yeah like it
yeah it's it's completely like like we
misses the point of the greater aspect
of it okay a couple other things I want
to touch on with you number one you
talked about the sort of environmental
benefit of veganism in my research it
seems the real environmental benefit is
in the reduction of meat consumption
particularly red meat and a few other
specific types of meat do you agree that
in terms of health there's no evidence
that veganism verses for example the
Mediterranean diet which limits meat
consumption is healthier there there in
all the research I've done
there's no truly extensive
all-encompassing study that says that a
vegan diet is healthier yeah well well
for one I've not done extensive
extensive extensive research on I I've
not read every study on on PubMed about
health benefits are not health benefits
with the the vegan diet quite honestly I
don't think that many studies have been
done on the vegan diet especially very
large scale study is like like things
look like the Mediterranean diet um in
terms of in terms of what's the the
greatest benefit for for the the planet
was that what you said before yeah well
no I was just sort of seeing if we were
on the same page that there's no doubt
that reducing meat consumption is good
environmentally but that in terms of
human health there's no evidence that
says veganism is is the healthiest diet
well healthiest this guy look like to me
health is kind of a continuum it's not
this is healthy versus this is unhealthy
right it's more like it's healthier than
this is how the earth than that I mean I
guess you could probably say that a raw
fruit or vegetable might be considered
maybe the healthiest thing but again
that's still a little bit arbitrary
because there's different circumstances
sure but but even regardless though
quite honestly I don't cite studies in
in my thing in in in any of my things
that I write or or things that I talk
about even though I have a science
background I studied behavioral
neuroscience in school yeah
and we're research lab and we discussed
papers around the the lab table all the
time and I am peer-reviewed journals and
and everything and and I think science
is great I think science has an absolute
place however I don't talk about it in
the grand scheme of things because for
one anything that requires a statistical
analysis to show whether something is
more probable or less probable or
essentially whether they're saying this
is correct or this is not correct
go ahead honestly has a tendency to go
back and forth throughout the ages so so
I'm not even gonna go there what I'm
gonna go for is what is obvious and what
is what can be shown with with no
statistical studies whatsoever it's
obvious that animals require much more
food that you put into them then you get
out of them right that's just obvious
that doesn't require a paper it doesn't
require a study you have to feed animals
and especially in our case of factory
firms corn and soybeans and and even
alfalfa that requires tremendous amount
more more resources going into it be it
the actual food that we could be feeding
people be it water that is used to for
the agriculture and for all the the
steps involved the fuel for all the
transportation steps above there's a
whole
waste in all these intermediary steps
and that doesn't require any kind of
paper or say that's just obvious you can
see that there is waste and you're
getting less far less out than what
you're putting it how far should this be
taken with regard to even vegetables
right I mean there are vegetables like
avocado which also require
disproportionately more water for the
nutrients that you get out compared to
other particular vegetables I mean
should the should the environmental
argument even be applied within
vegetables like should we get rid of or
go away from vegetables that require
more water per nutrient density what is
the thing if you got rid of the meat in
general the water wouldn't even be a
question because there just be enough
water fair enough
ok let me ask you something about a
trend now in veganism that I've been
reading about this is the the bivalve
Egon ISM which is the idea that by
valves right clams mussels mollusks
scallops etc they're certainly animals
to some extent but the idea that they're
not sentient in any way and thus I've
increasingly been reading about vegans
who say I'm vegan but I eat specifically
bivalves I don't eat fish I don't eat
octopus but by bivalves i feel morally
ok eating in the same way that a
vegetable is alive but it is not
sentient where are you on the 5 Alf
debate yeah so actually I know we first
heard of this um
I guess about a year or so ago I didn't
even know this was a thing until then uh
here's one that first of all this is
mostly for people that live in the ivory
tower
ah again this is this uh this Villa song
if if we just get rid of animal
exploitation at the root then this is
not even a question well first of all by
valves and bolts and things they have
nerve ganglia and whether or not you
consider those formal brains I mean our
bodies have nerve ganglion that do lots
of subconscious computations for our
brain and they're basically like mini
brains so so you reject the idea
that bivalves aren't sentient in some
sense I think it's I think it's even
ridiculous to talk about and and yeah
like if I can't believe people are
focusing on that as opposed to just
getting rid of the exploitation of
animals in general well I guess the
question is are you exploiting a muscle
if you determine that it's it may be no
more sentient than a plant right if you
believe that then are you really
exploiting it yeah I mean again this is
like this is where if you focus on
fringe cases the ivory tower breaks down
like like the the pure theory if you
want to just go my pier theory of it
then who knows quite honestly pain is an
internal an internal phenomenon anyways
you can't really know whether anything
experiences pain well you can find it
but I mean I think that's a sort of
dangerous path to go down because
science science does know a lot about
pain right I mean I think it would be I
don't know that it's a good argument to
say we can't even really know because
then maybe plants feel pain and we
shouldn't be exploiting plants exactly
but what I'm saying is like is if you
take that that that argument of uh well
I don't think it's any more sentient why
not I mean it has nerves it has nerve
ganglion why is it like sentient of
course is a degree and again it's a it's
like it's like if if we just cut out
animal exploitation at the root that's
the core of veganism yeah not weird
fringe things hey do you eat honey I do
not you do not eat honey
alright well do you believe the bees are
exploited if we if we empty their their
uh the honeycomb I do I think I think we
should leave honey for the bees and
leave them well enough alone
alright Brian man oh it's the most
hardcore vegan we've ever had on the
show that's for sure known to many as
the vegan black metal chef check him out
on YouTube google him Brian thanks for
talking to us thank you so much I
appreciate the appreciat you Joe